Dynamic memory allocation is another important service that
is part of memory management. It's important, once
again, to make sure that memory allocation scales
with the size of the system. And in order
to do that, one possibility is to take
the heap space of the process and break it
up. So this is the logical address space
of a multi-threaded application. And in the logical address
space, everything is shared. But what we're going to do
is we're going to take this heap portion of the
address space and break it up into the portion
of physical memories that are associated with the nodes on
which these threads are executing. Suppose the mapping of
the threads of this particular application is such that
T1 and T2 are executing on N1. And T3
and T4 are executing N2, and it's a [INAUDIBLE] machine,
so there's a physical memory that is local to this
node N1. And therefore what I'm going to do is dynamic
memory allocation requests. If it is centralized, it'll be a
huge bottleneck. Instead, we're going to break up the heap and
say that this portion of the heap fits in the
physical memory that is close to N1. This portion of
the heap fits in the physical memory that is close
to N2, so dynamic memory allocation requests from these threads,
satisfied from here. From these threads, satisfied from here. That allows for
scale-able implementation of dynamic memory allocation.
The other side benefit that you
get by breaking up the heap space into these distinct physical memories
that it can avoid full shading across nodes of the paddling machine.